[Música]
semana passada uns dias atrás na verdade
eu recebi uma mensagem um relato na rede
social um cara falando também que ele
tinha acabado de largar a faculdade
porque não estava conseguindo cumprir
com as rotinas dele acadêmicas estava
usando muita pornografia um tempo antes
eu tinha recebido um outro relato de um
cara que falou que ele estava tão
estragado que ele chegava assistir
pornografia chorando
mas mesmo assim ele não conseguia parar
o que tem de tão existiu na pornografia
que faz com que tantas pessoas fiquem
presas dessa maneira vou contar um pouco
da minha história e da minha experiência
com tornou o artista visual
eu dependo da minha própria criatividade
para sobreviver porque minha profissão
não é reconhecido oficialmente nesse
país
eu não tenho um emprego fixo o salário
nem direitos trabalhistas e essa minha
sobrevivência por um tempo esteve
seriamente ameaçada e eu andava porque
andava muito desanimado em produtivo
triste não conseguia criar novos
trabalhos não tinha motivação para
vender o que eu tinha pronto e nessa
época eu morava sozinho e trabalhava em
casa e não tinha dinheiro para nada mas
graças a um vizinho que deixava uma
conexão de internet aberta
eu tinha acesso à internet eu passar um
bom tempo na internet
uma boa parte desse tempo passava
assistindo os sites pornô
é como ser um hábito praticamente
inquestionável no cotidiano
e eu lembro que quando era moleque não
era fácil ter acesso à pornografia desse
jeito você tinha que a revista escondido
comprar uma fita de vídeo dá um jeito e
20 esconder as coisas é muito diferente
hoje nós temos uma rede de sites online
24 horas por dia com milhares de de
vídeos rodando é só ter qualquer
dispositivo com acesso à internet que a
gente acessa essa complexa rede de sites
pra fins lucrativos
eu vou chamar de por outro hoje como foi
que entrou na minha vida oh oh oh
nêutron como que eu entrei nele é
puxando a memória lembro que foi em 2007
aproximadamente quando finalmente à
internet banda larga chegou na minha
casa no quarto
sete anos depois eu tô num quarto um fim
de tarde eu devia ter trabalhado o dia
inteiro mas não conseguiu produzir quase
nada porque tinha passado o dia
assistindo site pornô
lembro muito bem de necid olhar pela
janela e vê o fim de tarde e as pessoas
estavam indo pra casa do seu trabalho
encerrando um dia comum aquilo pareceu
tão distante para mim e aí eu olhei pro
tela do meu computador e eu vi o vídeo
no qual eu tinha acabado de me masturbar
eu senti um desgosto profundo
nesse dia eu acho que eu cheguei no meu
pior sim eu estava realmente esgotado
deprimido e eu tive uma intuição esse
dia eu pensei será que será que o
pornográfico está fazendo mal será que
ela pode estar prejudicando e eu fiz uma
na mesma hora eu fui fiz uma pesquisa na
internet pesquisando pra mim a grande
surpresa descobrir uma comunidade e
global online de milhares de pessoas em
sua maioria homens a maioria homens que
estavam sofrendo com o mesmo problema
que eu com histórias até mais trágicas
assim lhe relatos nos fóruns de
casamento arruinado famílias arruinada
empregos perdidos por conta disso queria
descobrir também uma boa notícia é que
existia muita gente se recuperando e
pegando o caminho de volta através de um
processo de regeneração que é chamado de
ruth e guti na minha não entendimento é
um conjunto de três coisas fúteis
fatores uma série de informações
conhecimentos que estão disponíveis
é um conjunto de práticas que podem ser
feitas
é um estado de espírito que precisa ser
absorvido e essas três coisas elas
funcionam interligadas
os conhecimentos que a gente tem hoje
que qualquer um aqui quem sabe a
interação do ser humano pornografia
o nosso cérebro e traz algumas respostas
acontece que o nosso cérebro é fácil de
ser enganado
eu estou olhando pra você pessoalmente
olhando pra você através de um monitor
ou feche os olhos e imagine o seu rosto
com riqueza de detalhes o meu cérebro é
basicamente a mesma coisa ele não
diferencia muito e te decorre disso é
que quando nós acessamos o plano trombos
que elas centenas de pessoas sem roupa e
transando nosso cérebro ele entende que
nós estamos diante de possíveis
parcerias reais
ele não faz essa diferenciação isso
ativa no cérebro uma coisa que a gente
tem chama circuito de recompensas é
basicamente um circuito que faz a gente
correr atrás das coisas necessárias à
nossa sobrevivência enquanto indivíduo
enquanto espécie então o circuito de
recompensa que faz você ir atrás de
comida e de água de estabelecer conexões
emocionais de trabalhar de fazer sexo e
que existe uma palestra do que fala
muito bem no circuito que é o grande
experimento pornô do dr wilson e o que o
que mais que a gente sabe além de sicco
de recompensas que é hiperativa lado
quando a gente entra no no no painel
tron
a gente sabe que hoje e é um
conhecimento relativamente novo que nós
não tínhamos que o cérebro ele está
sempre se transformando mudando ele é
plástico essa propriedade chama
neuroplasticidade neuroplasticidade que
permite a gente aprender novas
habilidades e aprender uma língua nova e
também fazem depender vista os novos
então quando nosso amigo nuno por nutron
que acontece não é o fato de os vídeos
estarem em hd que deixa o cara ipi
excitado piorado ele mas sim o fato de
ter infinitas parcerias múltiplos
parceiros
o sistema indica o circo de recompensa
de des para o cérebro de janeiro a
cidade vai se adaptando aquela situação
na prática o que acontece
quanto mais a pessoa busca pornografia
na internet mas o cérebro dela
data para buscar pornografia na internet
e com esgoto em um circuito de
recompensas por ele está sendo e
préstimo lado por infinitas parcerias
que a gente nunca vai ver no mundo real
ele chega numa situação de esgotamento e
quando ele se esgota e não se esgota
sobre pornografia se esgota para a vida
em geral
então é nessa hora que a vida começa a
ficar as coisas começam a ficar difíceis
nessa hora que o cara lá na faculdade
que o cara triste desanimado isso não
costuma ainda moveu uma pessoa parada
para discutir pornografia como surgiu
essa comunidade do rio butiá disfunção
erétil resumidamente insistindo nessa
rotina de pornografia surge um novo tipo
de disfunção erétil que a disfunção
erétil induzido por pornografia qualquer
diferença de disfunção comum a disfunção
induzir pornografia não pode ser
abordado pela medicina tradicional
porque os remédios que existem hoje eles
agem no pênis
o problema nosso amigo tá no circuito de
recompensa dele que não funciona mais
feliz e mais longe do cara chegando
nessa situação e se ponham espantou
quando eu fui perguntar o que eu vou
fazer eu quero agora falar da dá pra do
rebote na prática que é o rebote
como é esse processo de boot quer dizer
inglês alguma coisa como recomeço
reinicialização e ele tem três regras
muito básicas que tinham a seguinte é 90
dias sem masturbação ejaculação e sem
pornografia 90 dias é o tempo médio
alguns homens levam mais tempo os homens
a menos tempo mas há um tempo
considerado bom para fazer uma transição
saudável
segundo a regra é você pode fazer sexo
com pessoas reais isso foi possível
a terceira regra é que cada desvio se o
cara entra e assistir por benefício mas
talvez já atua a contagem começa do zero
pessoalmente eu levei dois anos para
conseguir 90 dias
nesse processo eu observei algumas
práticas algumas coisas que que
funcionaram muito bem pra mim funciona
muito bem para a maioria dos caras
a primeira coisa etapa zero é descartar
todo material pornográfico físico e
virtual que você tem que jogar fora tudo
que você
ved revista vídeo etc apague as coisas
no computador do seu celular
elimina suas contas em sites pornôs
comece do zero não deixa rastros na
seqüência tem três práticas básicas que
ajudam muito nesse processo o primeiro
diário de área onde você vai fazer a
contagem dos dias de um dia dois e você
vai relatar como você está se sentindo
esses dias eu lembro que quando eu tive
a primeira recaída grave
eu um dia cheio o diário e comecei a ler
e eu fui lembrando um pouco não estava
me sentindo bem confiante
como eu estava melhor aqueles dias e
isso me deu força pra retomar meu
repúdio
a segunda coisa prática de exercício
físico em seria uma atividade física na
sua vida porque principalmente nos
primeiros dias do rio butiá acumula a
tensão stress e além das práticas do
benefício na prática esportiva aquilo
vai te deixar mais tranqüilo é eu
costumava quando estava angustiado
costumava simplesmente sai andando sem
rumo à cidade
a terceira coisa que pode ser feita
começar a atividade nova é pensa em
coisas vai ter tempo livre agora mais
tempo livre que você tinha então pensa
em coisas que você gostaria de fazer
você não fez ainda escolher uma e começa
uma atividade nova
eu comecei a minha foi minha proposta
pra mim mesmo foi desenhado do dia além
de trazer uma paz interior e começar a
me trazer novos trabalhos eu de conhecer
disso aprendi a fazer tatuagem que hoje
é um ofício mas ofício que exercia
agora quem sabe as práticas queria falar
um pouco do do estado de espírito do rio
butiá eu acho que a gente em algum
momento a gente tem que questionar por
que que o corpo tanto atrás de
pornografia como que isso entrou na
minha vida porque é fácil hoje né
se eu entrar no banheiro ele está no
celular eu já tô nesse mundo que os
estímulos estão em todos os lugares na
televisão na mídia publicidade nas
músicas lembrou outro dia
recentemente estava no lugar de uma
televisão aqmi tinha uma trava se
tornado sintonizado uma emissora de tv
nós
e tinha uma dupla de homens dois
cantores ea música deles falava coisas
do tipo eu não estou fazendo nada eu
sozinho na balada eu to bêbado fácil
a outra música falava de uma semana de
trabalho de segunda sexta chegava ao fim
e finalmente na sexta e sábado ele poder
bebê e atrai as mulheres
eu questiono muito os valores são
transmitidos na mídia porque um minuto
de programa são televisiva vale muito
dinheiro a grade de programação
escolhida a dedo
então eu acho que eles querem passar uma
mensagem com isso
isso me deixou pensando será que tem
alguém que está se beneficiando da nossa
dedicação pornografia desse jeito você
tem alguém ganhando com isso eu lembro
que está vendo um vídeo pornô e pensando
nos valores que que nesse vídeo estava
sendo transmitida veja os valores
sociais valores da pornografia se
refletindo nos outros sites pornô vários
estereótipos e valores que tornam a vida
de muitas pessoas o verdadeiro inferno
estão sendo reproduzidas é o homem
branco geralmente ele é o cara rico da
história ou ele está em posição de poder
sobre alguém é o homem negro geralmente
é um típico gângster com um falou enorme
que está pronto para violentar a moça
loura a mulher negra ou a mulher de
qualquer etnia que não seja branca é uma
aventura sexual exótica
aliás qualquer coisa que não seja branco
tem a sua categoria no site pornô
você vai ver lá black e john brasil já
entrar na categoria brasil prevê que o
mundo faz a leitura que o mundo faz a
gente e eu percebi que minha sexualidade
estava atrelado a um exercício
repetitivo que bombardeava de valores e
visões de mundo que eu não concordo
e ainda assim mais do que disposto a
voltar ali todo dia quando essas
reflexões sentimentos foram se
encaixando de mim foi que eu entrei no
estado de espírito que me levou adiante
no rio butiá
guti um processo pessoal
ele não é ciência exata cada pessoa
passa de um jeito por ele
só que existem alguns desafios no
caminho algumas benefícios são esperados
que são compartilhados por muitas
pessoas
eu queria falar um pouco agora do dos
desafios
a primeira coisa é são os impulsos
sexuais sexuais não impulsos
masturbatórios à vontade você entrar no
site tornou e se masturbar
esse vai ser o seu maior problema no
início foi o meu é pode ser uma
verdadeira tortura eles vão vir os
impulsos e eles vão vir fortes e é muito
provável que você vá sucumbir um momento
ou outro é importante prestar atenção no
que diz parecis gatilhos impulso de você
a gente está sendo estimulado de todos
os lados na publicidade que explora o
corpo da mulher ou em um programa de
auditório onde tem dançarinas seminuas
que podem muito bem ser videográficos
pornô
é importante se manter atento e distante
dessas coisas eu acho que cancelar
televisão completamente por exemplo é
uma boa medida nessa fase e outro
desafio que para mim foi uma grande
surpresa para muitos é é o estágio que
nós chamamos de flash lite flash online
é uma alusão àquela linha do medidor de
batimentos cardíacos quando o coração
pára a estónia reta é um período onde a
libido ou simplesmente desaparece sua
energia sexual chega a 10 e muitos nomes
inclusive relatos de sensação de
encolhimento do do pênis pode ser muito
assustador porque eu me lembro de quando
estava passando pelo meu flat lá eu vi
um casal se beijando na rua e aquilo que
pareceu surreal para mim distante
impossível imaginar nada na minha vida o
meu flat land durou quase um mês
o relato de poucos dias teve relatos de
flash lite quase um ano
isso pode trazer um verdadeiro pânico
porque você não sabe quando é que a sua
energia vai voltar a se manifestar mas
ela volta está garantido a voltar e vai
votar de um jeito muito diferente de
falar um pouco dos benefícios do desse
processo que esperar de vantagens
vou contar minha história
zé pode ser lido em qualquer fórum de
ruth na internet
o primeiro é o sentir realmente muita
disposição física o meu vigor físico eu
comecei a dormir melhor dos primeiros
cuidar mais cedo outra coisa foi a
clareza mental muito grande que que vem
uma clareza que eu acho que nunca tinha
tido sem a qual não poderia estar
falando que hoje a minha memória
melhorou muito na percepção melhorou
muito na concentração melhorou muito mas
o que mais me surpreendeu foi a relação
com as outras pessoas
na época no rebote eu namorava e quando
eu fiquei nos 30 primeiros dias longe da
pornografia carioca estava 30 dias sem
ver a namorada mas mesmo período quando
a reencontrei é uma mulher linda mas
quando eu encontrei ela tava mais lindo
ainda estava reparando coisas que não
tinha parado nela assim pequenos
detalhes um jeito de falar urgente olhar
uma coisa eu fui falar escolha foi por
fez alguma coisa está tão bonita hoje
ela não fez nada demais aí eu comecei a
perceber que a minha visão estava
diferente minha percepção das pessoas
estava diferente na rua os lugares
eu percebi que estava sendo melhor
tratadas as pessoas fazer um contato
visual comigo trocar uma idéia mas eu
percebi que eu estava também mais
receptivo estava olhando para as pessoas
estava interessado em saber o que nós
estamos querendo dizer pra mim
cumprimentando as pessoas na rua e outra
coisa que acontece uma revolução na sua
sexualidade muito profunda
para mim existe o sexo antes dos santos
depois no rebote
eu poderia ficar falando horas dos
benefícios mas no tempo já está chegando
no final e eu queria falar que o
primeiro é um recorte de um homem branco
heterossexual é necessário que eu não
posso falar por outras pessoas então é
necessário que tem outras vozes fala
disso voz dos homossexuais e das
mulheres por exemplo não sou
especialista no assunto não sou
especialista em nada na verdade eu venho
compartilhar vim compartilhar uma
história na esperança de ser útil para
alguém de trazer à luz nesse assunto
eu queria dizer que se tem alguém que
com esse problema conhece alguém que
tenha esse problema saiba que as
informações estão disponíveis
existe muito conhecimento muita gente
trocando idéia internet sobre isso
infelizmente maioria língua inglesa
mas as coisas estão aí
se você quiser mudar se tiver um desejo
forte mudança você tem todas as
ferramentas para operar essa mudança
fique tranquilo que vai dar certo muito
obrigado
[Aplausos]